take two apple
Mark okay we're good we're good do I say
action I am the Ghost of Christmas
present you're going full Dickens on me
get ready something very special is
about to happen
[Music]
oh that's just fun to
watch
[Music]
grab my hand we're doing this we're
doing it it's going to be quite a
ride Sean gave me a call and said we are
thinking about doing a brand new version
of Christmas Carol told from the
perspective of the
ghosts and then he said oh and it's a
musical 4 5
6 hey I can tell you that will Ryan and
I we all had a little Panic feeling a
little insecure about
dancing Ryan and I started talking we're
like we should really document how bad
we
[Music]
are and hopefully there'll be some
improvement my wife made old jelly tap
shoes that is spectacular socks bring
the whole together making someone wear
jelly tap shoes is assault I think in
several States that's probably legal but
will of course being will put them right
on and went did a little number in fact
roll the
[Music]
[Applause]
clip don't you hate it when you jelly
nobody American anymore
between acting notes dance notes music
notes your brain is like trying to play
you know 3D chess and I'm only good for
Checkers before it's all too late too
late before it's all too
[Music]
L full disclosure we're not doing well
yep tiny thing but any way that we put
that gladle on Ian would always come up
with three quick things two quick things
cool uh-huh I still don't know what a
gladle is I would never ask what it
meant I would just agree then I would
get a you nailed it that was a lot of
extra gladle it's probably about 50%
more and that's sort of what I was
looking for i' be like great great I
really glott the out of that I used to
think that I was sure of what made
people tick you strip them down right to
their core and find a self-centered
prick I feel very lucky to be a part of
this it's so fun so can we do a little
doing it
again for Ryan and I and Octavia to go
through the dance and the singing it's
just been such a
[Music]
joy you can't really put a price on
having fun it's just special and
incredible every second of it been
pretty
[Music]
amazing do a little girl do a little
girl
a
[Applause]
[Music]
that was invigorating I've never done
that before that was
fun